comme on essaie produits en ligne et
venir les récupérer plus tard c'est le
nouveau fonctionnement adoptée par les
halles de wazemmes depuis ce jeudi
les commerçants du marché couvert de la
préfecture du nord se sont adaptés aux
nouvelles consignes sanitaires annoncé
par le gouvernement le 23 mars dernier
en concertation avec les pouvoirs locaux
les commerces alimentaires optent pour
le drive piétons afin d'assurer la
livraison de leurs produits aux
habitants de la ville
ce qu'il faut c'est offrir aux habitants
du quartier
un choix de
d'alimentation un choix de
d'approvisionnement là où ils le
souhaitent de la façon dont ils veulent
donc c'est pour ça que les commerçants
réfléchit à 7 7 6 solutions de drive
avec d'un côté la prise de commande et
de l'autre la le retrait de la
marchandise elles peuvent en primeur
boucher et autres commerçants peuvent
ainsi écouler leur production
une adaptation indispensable en effet
leur activité est fortement menacé par
la baisse de fréquentation constatée
dans ce marché couvert
en moins de gens
à l'intérieur des halles - deux jours à
l'extérieur
plastique dans le schéma d'une rencontre
sur les gens pour venir
wes visite parce que
très attachés à l'activité dans dé plus
vaste marché couvert d'europe
les lillois soutiennent l'initiative
des commerçants et au calme à la lecture
[Musique]
fall était dans l'habitude d'acheter des
le produit de pouvoir contacter pour
cela favoriser les petits producteurs
et puis pouvoir être d'or est un petit
peu de marche
on a dit on a livré deux agréables avec
l'annoncé vendredi du prolongement du
confinement pour 15 jours
le nouveau fonctionnement des halles de
wazemmes devrait donc perdurer